la célébration était au niveau de la
décharge d'énergie déployée par le rc
versailles ce dimanche les joueurs de la
cité royale se qualifier en quarts de
finale du championnat de france honneur
après une victoire dans le derby vinoy
contre le mls gp ce qu'en finale a trait
à trois gros match on savait on a on n'a
pas forcément réussi à produire ce qu'on
aurait voulu produire aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup subi et on est allé chercher
avec les tripes parce que c'est vraiment
dur quand cette équipe de des maisons
laffitte terrain h f
une victoire acquise en grande partie
grâce à une défense resserrée dans les
derniers mètres qui a perturbé leurs
adversaires je vais récupérer une vidéo
donc je savais un peu comme jouer donc
on avait mis en place un système de
défense par kaka fonctionner avec des
avec des couloirs une défense de fer
qu'il faudra revoir au prochain tour les
versets y affronteront chalon sur saône
une des meilleures équipes de division
honneur est candidat au titre
versailles devrait aller battre pour
continuer à rêver de la montée lorsqu'on
ce qu'on vaut face à une grosse équipe à
son pression aucune voilà pour le coup
on a rarement par la pression donc allé
voir ce qu'on vaut kadhafas et des
semi-pros vallières on sait que c'est
très compliqué on verra en fonction des
résultats et à des tapis verts etc
on peut pas vraiment calculé sur les
phases finales après on prend les
matches les uns après les autres on aura
un gros match dans deux semaines on sait
qu'il ya un énorme morceau qui va nous
attendre après bah voilà on n'est pas
morts on est encore là et tant qu'on est
là il va falloir nous taper la rencontre
sera programmée le dimanche 10 juin sur
terrain neutre entre la bourgogne et
l'yonne
les supporters versez y ait eu un rêve
déjà d'un nouvel exploit de leurs
protégés
[Applaudissements]